hello and welcome to this video I got
black again how many blacks in a row can
you get three blacks in a row Wow
okay so shouldn't screw that up here
with my team as sometimes jerky got this
normal enormous tea pot the first one or
two servings are
Tajima
it's surprising how many players do this
just blunder the d4 pawn yeah here I can
take on d5 I can take here right and it
doesn't work at all
[Music]
hmm I don't know I mean I'm just
developing right here not sure that
Queenie for is helping right I think
rather not
okay so how do we continue him it would
be best if he didn't even manage to
castle that that would be the goal here
trying to enjoy a fivesome idea so that
I have the maximum pressure one denied
so let's go down and probably castling
queenside is also on what why does that
work he somehow keep stumbling into a
Forks and it cannot work
yeah there was a bit of an opening and
opening disaster
it happens actually quite often I had
this on the board a lot a bishop aged
voice just a blunder after g5g for and
if you go Bishop g5 you should do it
with the intention of provoking h6 and
then dropping back to the tool I think
this is actually a good move to provoke
in many positions later on black Rada
would would want to have the pawn on h7
then on h6 so this is fine position that
I've played myself quite a bit with
white the and here you're just in bad
shape dropping a big Center pawn try to
d5 and now Queen e4 which probably
doesn't help either yeah now there's
this double threat and what can you do
92 so this is the next one
dropping look you won yeah I think this
should be okay Queen to a5 is a good
plan now he has a hard time we can
develop the bishop probably like here
and then I Castle queenside and now
again he has got no movie cannot castle
short as I take you to and that's
basically end of game but this is just
dropping another piece so this shows
that this line is no good with Bishop
Age form yeah white has reasonable
chances for small advantage after Bishop
d2 that is a line that I have
recommended for black in my name is a
BOGO book and as I already admit in the
book this is probably not completely
equal yeah this this line with 96 it has
one advantage it needs to relatively
simple to play positions you're not
really yeah having you don't have to
solve very sophisticated problems with
black in the first couple of moves but
why should be slightly better if he
knows what he's doing okay guys thanks
for watching